hi this is an interview with people from
lyon whose flagship projects are data
sets specifically data sets to train
models like dali or clip so pictures and
text that goes along with the pictures
they scrape these from big internet
scrapes the first data set had 400
million images and their newest data set
has 5 billion images these are
unprecedented scales to be open sourced
as data sets the creators of dali or
clip openai they never disclose their
data set they never put it out there in
public and lion does so this is a big
service to the community and i was super
excited to have them on here another
thing is just how grassroots this
movement is the founder christoph who's
also here today is a father and a
teacher and does this on the side just
as a hobby and sort of wants to
demonstrate a little bit how anyone can
take part in open source research now
multiple times during the interview his
kids would actually come in and be like
daddy play with us and so on youtube is
very strict on this i cannot show the
kids even though the kids themselves
would have loved to appear in this
youtube video so you know kids please um
i'm very sorry it took me a zelit when
you are inside open invitation often an
iron laden feeling channel i thought
this was really cool and inspiring in
addition to learning what lion is about
enjoy the interview let's dive right in
hey everyone today i have the team
behind lion5b with me christoph schumann
roma bomo and kate gordon are here who
contributed to this project in various
ways which i hope they'll just tell us
about in a second this is a giant data
set it's over 5 billion image text pairs
so not just images but image text pairs
and along with that an open clip model
open sourced clip model that matches the
performance of open ai's clip model
which is really cool these
these big companies
they rarely give out their biggest
models if any if you know if at all and
if they give out their biggest models
they usually don't give the data set
behind the model so it's really cool
that we have like a large data set uh
there has been some controversy
around your
smaller data set that you released i
want to say half a year or a year ago i
hope we can get into all of that today
but first of all uh
thank you very much for being here
welcome to the channel
welcome nice to be here yeah um just
maybe tell me a little bit uh what is
lion and what is lion 5b
so it all started
like 10 months ago i guess
on the elute ai server when we talked
about how could we eventually replicate
dali and where could we get like
200 300 400 million image text pairs
and
there was this idea of going to common
crawl
and looking for all the image links and
only take those that have an alternative
text
and we have been talking about this in
the multimodal channel there together
with aaron and ben bang
and
they got a little bit distracted with
the project of gptj
so they ended up focusing totally on
gptj and i was sitting there and was a
little bit upset and thought hmm why
don't they pursue this because i um
compared to them felt like someone who
is not that a good prank programmer
and
then i thought okay
screw it i just do it myself and i
sat down and wrote everything down in
one poll up and began crawling from
common crawl and filtering with clip
and then more and more people joined me
at first theo comes um he
he was the first to join me and so we
called it crawling at home
because
at first we had some call up notebooks
and some gpu somewhere on
from some people on the discord servers
and they were all like downloading and
filtering downloading filtering and
uploading the results to a rented server
and yeah and after a while more and more
people joined like richard who is not
here at the moment but he's also a very
valuable cool contributor
richard benku
and
we optimized the code so that we could
filter and crawl
with one 30-90 in one day
um
30 million image text pairs
after the filtering not before so in the
end we ended up like at the peak with
like
30 and well no
60 or 100 small
mini servers downloading the images
sending them to richard richards gpu in
his bedroom filtering everything and
spitting out
in the quality of like conceptual
captions 12 million what was uh was the
biggest then at least the time and
12 million image taxpayers
of decent quality and we could generate
with 1390 within one day
30 million
and at this point we said oh wow
we should really scale this up and um i
asked someone like we already had some
people on discord who gave us their cpus
gpus and so it grew and grew but then it
was clear that we could get um was only
the nations we got from the community
could get to 400 million what would be
like the scale of open ai clip data set
because clip was trained initially on
100 million
image taxpayers
and i said okay
we can get to 1 billion if we would get
like maybe 5 000 of donations for paying
for small cpu servers and maybe some
gpus somewhere i don't know
and i asked on the luther ai
server and within like 10 minutes
someone said oh if it's only 5000 i will
pay it upfront
has like a startup
um it's uh jack from doodlebot ai
and yeah he ended up giving us in the
end like ten thousand dollars so he was
our first official sponsor
and um
i have to say the i dot eu also provided
us with some compute but the first
sponsor who gave us money and then i
said okay i don't want to have this
money on my bank account and we probably
for now and for the future should start
a non-profit
and then came jenny who is not here at
the moment januarjitsev he's the lab
leader of the um deep learning
laboratory it's a unique supercomputing
facility
um
and
yeah we had been in touch and he said
okay we we will join with our people
because we want to train models like
dali or clip
on
uh the unix super computer like jewels
it's a giant machine with almost 4000
a100s
and he cannot directly access it in
trinidadi but he can access it for proof
of concept small projects and then apply
and so we said okay let's start a
non-profit and we take this as a shell
for basically getting money getting
resources officially
and then spending it for creating cool
data sets and
training models and giving them away for
free no fees 100 open
because we were
i mean we were a little bit disappointed
by the promise that opmay i made by the
name
of open ai and many people had been
joking a closed ai
and
i totally understand that if you get two
billion dollars of funding that you have
some strings attached and that you have
some protocols and problems and that
there you have security
safety concerns
but we said okay we don't have the means
to do all the basic research but we can
try to do what they were doing what
microsoft is doing what google brain is
doing and just taking the code or
replicating the code and
releasing such models for free
and then we started the german
non-profit effect the minded sign in
germany
and
yeah ever since everything took up off
we released the 400 million data set
and less than one hour later i got mail
from
thomas wolf from hugging face and i got
also in contact with many more people
and
everyone wanted to talk to us and
now we also get some mandatory
support from hungerface that also
enabled us to do the big data set
and we have stability ai who is
providing us with gpus and will provide
us in the future with more gpus
we have an ongoing application for 600
000 gpu hours on joules we don't have
like the result yet but
in one month we should know for training
a big clip model and applying this to
some downstream tasks
so yeah
everything is moving very fast and one
year ago i was just like a family daddy
and a
computer science teacher so i'm
i'm a computer science teacher
and um everything developed very quickly
and now
romaine who is also like an awesome guy
with much of experience and the cool
tools like image to text
image to data set tool that you already
introduced in your
you know ml news i remember
and gay kade who is a really brilliant
um
computer science student who is really
into clip and he helped us to train a
clip and replicate the results of
the
vision transformer 32 base
um and we matched
roughly with the small variations
sometimes a little better sometimes a
little bit worse on several data sets
um the performance with the eurasia
performance of the original clip so yeah
everything's looking really nicely we
have no intentions of
going for profit we have
we agree that we want to stay open
we agreed that we want to stay
non-profit for several reasons
and um
everyone who likes to contribute or to
talk to us maybe someone has some
questions maybe someone is curious about
something
everyone can join
our discord server and just ping us ask
us
cool um
so
i want to dive into sort of the biggest
uh criticism that i would have with this
project in that your data set
essentially crawls common crawl for
image text pairs and i'm going to guess
that's image and the associated alt text
or whatever text you find with the image
and then you have this filtering step is
what you say you can do a lot of images
on a single gpu but you're essentially
using open ai's clip model to filter
image text pairs which
clip deems to be you know fit together
well right so i
isn't does that like how much of a
how much of a bias does that introduce
into a data especially now if you say
well we train a clip model on this data
set right and we we're able to match the
performance of openai's clip model
one could ask you know is this are you
essentially replicating the result or
are you simply uh
matching their performance because the
data set is already essentially filtered
to
you know the data points that are
conducive to that model so could you
dive a little bit into your choices
there and how much do you feel that is
an important step this filtering what
does it like what's the what does it
give to the data set
um to use that and do you have plans to
maybe switch that up or improve that
part
so no one um claimed that this would be
perfect but before i did this
i started with
jfcc 100 and i filtered this also
i filled it basically on call up and
yeah whatever and and i checked a lot of
image text pairs manually and i just got
the feeling after looking at thousands
of images in text pairs that
point 28 was a pretty good threshold
like that
if you go above the threshold with the
clip b32 from ope
then
it really seems to match pretty well
it's still a little bit noisy but it
rule of thumb
and if you go above 0.3 it's even a
little bit better not perfect but a
little bit better and
this is what we have this is not the
ultimate solution for everything but
i think because we are going so big and
crawling over so many images
that are you made by humans the
annotation were made by humans
that in the end we will still get like a
lot new information in
and it could be that some
people maybe some names of people that
the original um clip has not learned or
some concept some nouns or some
adjectives that has not learned could go
below this could always happen
but um
yeah i mean from the standard benchmarks
that we ran the results are pretty good
and everything is work on progress yeah
i don't i don't doubt the quality aspect
of filtering with openai's clip what i'm
a bit worried about is that you're
essentially replicating what how this
model sees the world right this model
isn't perfect either and so it will it
will sort of replicate its own
you know vision of the world into your
data set and especially if you then
train a clip model right that would that
would be replica have you tried uh just
training a clip model on let's say an
unfiltered um data set
um or what could also be possible if you
have many different such models that
somehow estimate quality of images and
text that you could build some sort of
an ensemble um i don't know if you have
plans in the future to to replace this
filtering step or make it better is that
something you have on your radar
i guess what one thing we do have is the
unfiltered pairs like we have actually
10 times this like we have 50 billion
filter pairs
and yeah there could be some work to
that could be done analyzing these pairs
and trying to see if it's different
uh but the prime of just using them is
when you lower the quality a lot on i
don't know if we do what it would do but
yeah it's definitely an interesting
we don't fully have your answer on but
i think this is one of the points that
we become more apparent when we start to
train the larger clip models so at this
moment it was like line 400 m so that
was the initial data set that we had
just that subset and getting in the
range of open ai is at least sufficient
enough to prove that we've at the bare
minimum been able to like replicate the
exact like
inferences of the model and get into
like sort of like that convex hole so to
speak of its like confidence threshold
i think the more interesting result will
come into play as soon as we hit the 5
billion scale and we get up to that
larger threshold if we're able to sort
of like push the numbers that opening i
got before it could also be in response
to the fact that we have like maybe
different image towers and text towers
sure that but if we can outperform what
open ai did within their original models
it could be a sign that the data set was
able to get like just enough
stochasticity to go outside of like
perfect confidence again it's in the
future and it's not a result that we
have but we're optimistic in seeing what
it lies did you like how big is your
data set just give me some some numbers
in terms of like gigabytes like what can
i expect if i work with this thing
uh so 240 terabytes
240 terabytes
yeah if you download it in a
384 resolution
and you have you have differences okay
so you collected if different images can
you give me some numbers on that like
what kind of resolutions do you have uh
how long are the descriptions usually
just kind of some so people can imagine
a little bit what what this looks like
uh i think you if you open the
blog post the blog post yeah
yeah yeah
um here
yeah so
like for example the english part
is
is 2 billion samples and then if you
can't only the ones that are bigger uh
both in width and 8 than 256 it's like a
billion and then alpha for
fps resolution and yeah
so
it's a lot of images which have a decent
resolution but if you want to train like
a
like let's say a highly quality high
quality generative model or maybe
segmentation model maybe you want to use
a high resolution subset
yeah in term of uh
caption lens
uh yeah i want to add the precise number
in that in that section but
um yeah it's around like uh
i think it's around 200 characters but
yeah that's a good question i i should
add that i completed it at some point
but i think i didn't yeah
i saw it just a second ago yeah
um
yeah yeah so it's a long tail actually
because like we have like 100 uh
languages
and yeah the first one we have a lot of
samples but then yeah you have this long
tail of many other languages that are
available
um
but yeah for example you have 70 you
have a seven percent of the much longer
data set which is a french
do you always have one piece of text
with an image or do you sometimes have
multiple because a lot of these data
sets that are captioning data sets and
so on they provide kind of multiple
labels for one image there it's just one
image one piece of text okay and that is
is it always the alt text of the image
or do you sometimes like grab
text around
this is like um
work for the future so
in the future we want to build an audio
text data set with a similar approach so
currently we have some people
working on
training a small or mid-sized audio clip
model on existing
[Music]
data sets and once we have one of
sufficient quality we could go through
all
of common crawl filter out all
links to audio files
and try to somehow get something like
the old text because usually there is no
alt text but we could like look if
they're immediately before the link or
after the link is some text that has a
sufficient
audio clip similarity and
there is there are many ideas but um
if anyone would like to join us and work
on this
everyone can join we are truly open
just get onto the
discord server and
stay here
so so yeah so go ahead
yeah um
two things that
you had been talking about previously
so what could we do to
make clip
recognize more things that had not been
in the original clip data set
and one interesting perspective for this
that is still work in progress but um
that could maybe work
is we are experimenting currently with a
training clip with a frozen image
encoder
and
one idea that we have is to train a
masked image of the encoder
something like sim mim or the mae from
facebook meta
and
then we could train it on many many
images with all texts
and so the basic idea is
that if you have a really good
image encoder that can be trained in a
self-supervised manner without any text
there then the limit is the sky because
like in theory we could get like 50 or
100 billion images from common crawl we
uh do not pursue this at the moment
because like
um 5 billion is enough for the next few
years i guess
but
so the idea is to train a really good
image encoder in a septuagist fashion
and then we freeze it and we can train
it with
text strength a text encoder
and i guess in this case we would have
much knowledge from the self-supervised
training about what is actually an image
and we wouldn't need the clip filter
data we could take any data set
and this could help with this so we're
exploring
we are cooperating at the moment with a
globe team um with andreas first who is
the first author of the globe
paper like this is an improvement of the
original
clip architecture with some hopfield
layer magic
so let's see
what happens so um tell me a bit about
what it takes to because these are
unprecedented scales for for most people
by the way there's a nice overview here
over the um over the entire acquisition
pipeline which is is really nice
distributed at all and then you train
this clip model now the clip model you
have currently you already set it is on
the uh on the 400 m data set uh which is
the let's call it the old it's not super
old but it's it's your previous data set
which is on the scale of clip and you
trained a clip model on this
what does it take to work at let's call
it at that scale right imagenet is one
million images and that's already
considered like a rather large data set
for most researchers that have like a
gpu or something like this right 400
million is almost i would say most
people probably aren't working with this
size of data is it easy is it hard like
how do you go about training this model
so there's like two large contexts for
this this is whether or not you're in
like your large hpc cluster or if you're
in more so just like your generic data
farm so at least these results were
supported by joules booster and
foundation which upholds that um
there it's also a very large
institutional barrier of even like
getting to the batch size that they
offered so in terms of data set alone
you have to have everything like stored
on disk and that is a nightmare in
itself getting it collected and that
just in terms of memory is probably not
accessible to most researchers then you
get an extra layer which is the exact
batch size of clip there have been other
papers that have shown that these large
multimodal contrastive models are like
extremely batch size dependent basic has
a really good table on this and
it's hard enough to get to your data set
alone hard enough to get the
infrastructure just to support that but
on top of that can you get your massive
a100 cluster to actually spin this up
and one thing they don't talk about is
the massive engineering struggle that
goes into actually doing contrastive
loss on this um let alone if you just
take a 32 000 by 32 000 matrix it's like
two gigabytes an fp 16 or four gigabytes
if you're doing full precision and that
just becomes a nightmare of overhead and
so the wonderful team that i've been
working with
this model is just as much mine as it is
theirs um we've been
putting a lot of our time into just how
to optimize the small things like for
instance
when doing contrastive learning you
don't actually need entire global
batches you can do only certain
calculations that are necessary for your
local gradient routine so on and so
forth but
to achieve this scale there are a lot of
challenges that these large research
labs don't like talking about because
they're not as pretty to write on the
paper
but
this isn't very accessible immediately
for like everyday researchers and we
think this is something very important
for other people to get their hands on
and so
hopefully this will inspire more
companies to give out the compute
necessary to accomplish results like
these and inspire further researchers to
uptake in this direction
you also mentioned that your original
plan was to train something like dolly
right and clip is an important component
of dolly is this still on your radar to
eventually train something like dolly
because there are other projects going
on i know there's like mini dali and
other people trying to replicate dolly
like what's your your thoughts on
replicating dolly
yeah there's so much going on and it's
incredible um
so they had been from lucid reigns uh
the pie torch dali project and we
actually tried this on jewish booster so
we got this to run on
i don't know maybe 256 a 100s for 10
minutes
and um it would work in theory but the
thing is
ah my son is here one second daniel
he has
rubber balls
okay
danny i need time okay
kids are important so this is very
really awesome about all of this
you know what i'm doing like on the
discord servers i'm doing this when i'm
on the playground i'm doing this while
i'm playing minecraft with my kids i'm
doing this when i'm at the shopping
center like from my mobile so
i can do this in my free time and this
is really amazing
but um what was that talking about
what it is
yeah so the thing is with dali um
we could have pursued this and we had to
make the decisions at first we wanted to
apply for uh compute on jewels last
august for like a half a million
gp wars for creating dali but we missed
the deadline because we were so busy
with line 400
and um then i had a realization others
are working on darling dali minnie is
there and min dali and you have like a
who darlee and now the fusion models and
i said hey
clip is actually
not that amazing in the on the first
lens but on the second lens it's
far more amazing because you can use it
to guide generated models you can use it
to make huge data sets you can use it to
create
semantically meaningful embeddings and
this alone is very interesting because
like um i had this idea and luther
people had also this idea that maybe one
could like take images and texts
and do sequence modeling
on the clip embeddings so you wouldn't
do the sequence modeling on the image
tokens or on the text tokens but maybe
on the
abstract ideas so i compare it like it's
not 100
accurate maybe but it's like a metaphor
so if i'm thinking about i want to go to
the fringe and get some food and want to
do this i'm not really imagining
everything in full hd resolution and i'm
not thinking oh i will go to the fridge
so i'm more like having the idea in a
kind of mixed
embedding space idea space
and so um one thing that we have in mind
is like something in the future maybe
not now
but if it would eventually work to
take
embeddings from audio from video from
text from from all modalities and bring
them into the same embedding space and
then somehow bring a transformer to
model them
this would be really interesting because
you could like
train it on
a text on video and everything and
could do it in a very very efficient way
and uh luther people had been working on
this
they got many uh not number errors from
feeding in the direct clip embeddings
because it's probably just like too too
big to unstable with all the noise in
the clipping buildings
but i have the hunt that clip is really
powerful and i didn't realize this when
i first read about it but i think
so the idea
you have gpt kind of models they are
sequence learners
they can model sequences of whatever of
images of text of all kinds of data
and you have something like clip that
can take different modalities basically
any modality
and convert it somehow into a shared
embedding space and i think these
both topics are a little bit
disconnected in the moment at the moment
but in the future there's very much room
left to the ceiling
to combine them
maybe do something like quantization of
the clip embeddings or whatever like i i
i have no clue
exactly but i could really imagine that
in the future
if we could get all modalities into a
semantic shared semantic space and find
a sequence learner to model this
this i i have no idea i i maybe
i
don't dare to dream of aging or so in
this or the connection but i can really
see
similarities that in my stream of
consciousness when i think okay i want
to go there then it happens this and i
do action x
and action y
this is not so different
yeah
well there's a debate of whether you
need to uh actually interact with the
world to achieve agi right i think
that's the big hurdle um the other thing
is there's this model or this paper
called cm3 i don't know if you've seen
that um they are
doing something very similar to what you
just suggested with actually quantizing
the the images after encoding them uh
with it with an image model and then
using an auto aggressive
model in order to to model that so maybe
that that might be some ideas maybe i
can i can say a few words about your
initial or your previous question of
about the the size of of things and how
do we under it
um
i think maybe i have a slightly
different perspective
um because for me what was interesting
in this project is to be able to do all
of this with actually little resources
uh because
yeah it's pretty big but for example the
400 million data set
um
just with some python cards uh pretty
optimized you can actually download it
with like only one machine and three
days
which i think
yeah that's that's pretty good um at
this scale you only have like 10
terabyte of data so you can actually
store it at home and it's not that
expensive
and i think that's pretty interesting
because i think that was one of the
things that made it possible for like
many researchers to
get lyon 400m and start
applying to various ideas like we have
we had a bunch of papers trying to
took it and train some generative models
train some contrastive models
uh that kind of
things
and uh and yeah and the story is a bit
similar but of course a bit more costly
with these new data sets so i had to
make everything distributed so now it's
like uh 10 nodes and not one
uh to the led it's in a reasonable time
but still it's not in domain of
reasonable like you can you can have it
without being a very large company
uh
yeah and uh
and yeah and following up a bit on this
idea is um
so one of the things we did as
processing of these datasets is like
downloading everything and computing all
the coupon but things out of that and
then putting that in a canon index and
that's the
the ui the demo
and i think one of the idea
behind that is sure you can export the
data you can look for cats or whatever
you want
but you can also use that kind of
index to extract new sub data sets that
are much more much smaller and that can
be interesting to
uh to train uh
let's say
smaller things and
uh
solve
more specific problems so maybe you want
to build to find all the pizzas
from the world and i don't know get
inspiration for your restaurant
uh yeah
yeah or you can for example uh try to
build some kind of subset
out of lion 400m
or lion
like for example christopher has been
starting a project to
find all the humans in the data set and
see what's there what can we understand
from that
and yeah and i think what's interesting
is that it all obviously democratize our
research like it becomes possible to
actually build that kind of stuff
without having too much resources
and uh yeah i hope that we can uh
it makes it possible and
and yeah and that people player with all
the tools on the data sets
you i see you you're storing the uh the
data set on s3 which
does
i know like uh luther stores their data
set on on the i which which supplies
these resources i know s3 has like
significant charges for egress right if
people download this that you incur
quite some cost uh i think they have
like 20 cents per gigabyte which would
be like 200 bucks per terabyte
so at 200 terabytes someone downloading
the data set would cause you something
like uh
30 000
40 000 dollars or so yeah um what is
that this is this is what your sponsors
are they're there for or do you have
like a deal with with amazon
no we
we are very lucky
so we we are very lucky um
our sponsor for compute at the moment
our main sponsor for the gpus and for
this with s3 storage
is stability ai
and um their plan is actually to gather
resources from different
companies investors who actually want
cool multimodal models openly available
because they want to use them but they
don't want to build an ml team or hire
people or so and he has many connections
amad he's the
ceo or the founder of stability ai
and he has a very good deal with aws
and um we won't share
the aws files that we have because we
don't own the copyright of the pictures
but we are sharing the metadata the urls
and so everyone on his own his or her
own liability and risk could download
them from the original
sources
we recommend that if you do this you
make sure that the dataset is
shuffled nicely it's or it's already
shuffled i guess right yeah
and um
so when we started the project we got
problems because we didn't properly
shuffle them and sometimes some
uh webmasters complained that we would
downloading too much from them and the
data center where we were
renting the machines
got some complaints but if you shuffle
it properly and you download it
over all the 5 billion image tax pairs
there is no problem usually
and um with the wonderful two tool image
to data set that remain programmed and
that now also
supports distributed downloading with
the swarm of cpu workers
one could
download it for
relatively small money i mean romey can
just tell more about this yeah yeah uh
for sure yeah that's a big
thing i think that makes it possible for
us to share the data sets like uh lion
400 m
is 10 habits in images but the metadata
is only
50 gigabytes which is quite honorable
and same for lion5p the image is 240
terabytes but the
metadata itself is about
one terabyte which is honorable and then
yeah you can use that image to that
asset tool to
get the data uh
which works well of course there will be
some link hearts and you will start
losing a bit of data with time but
it's a pretty reasonable the total
amount of data and about the cost yeah
to do another legon uh 5b if you use
some adobe us instance i think the cost
should be like 1000
which
is not nothing but it's not like the 40k
you have a martial about you guys yeah
okay so it won't it won't cost it won't
bankrupt you and it won't bankrupt me if
i download this data yeah exactly yeah i
see that and for the future there's a
new direction that we are exploring at
the moment or the the hive mind project
is exploring
so um
they working they are working on some
code that would allow you to directly
stream the images
from the urls
so you
download them you buffer them somewhere
and if you have like a decent internet
connection that
this should actually work so um last
time lxb from the live mind project he's
also on our discord he told me that they
could reliably um
train like 50 to 60 images per second
and for a small model this would not be
sufficient so we would get a bottleneck
but if you go to something like a vision
transformer capital g or capital h
the training takes so much time
that
it wouldn't matter so you could like
train a capital h vision transformer
with this and you would need only maybe
100 gigabyte or so storage on your
machine
that is interesting that the models they
get so big that essentially that the
bottleneck shifts away from the internet
connection to the to the cluster forward
propagation that's pretty cool
um but you mentioned a good point in
terms of releasing these kinds of data
sets and the the uh not technical
challenges but let's call legal
challenges social challenges and so on
uh
you
you already mentioned there's obviously
issues with copyright uh so any image
that that you have if you want to
reproduce it you technically uh need to
have some sort of a
a license to it or you'll
be a criminal in some country in the
world for sure
so you only have the links you solve
that part pretty well
the but there has been there's been
criticism i think with respect already
to your earlier data set specifically i
remember about two weeks uh after it was
released like insanely fast there was a
paper uh
while like criticizing
it was it was framed in a weird way like
it was half criticizing your data set
and half criticizing the large companies
for not releasing their their tools to
filter these data sets and could you
maybe um
summarize a little bit what that
criticism was
of your data set and
what was the issue
so basically the issue was that um the
authors said if i remember correctly
that our data set is not properly
filtered and that if you go to our web
demo or to the raw data
you could find
stuff like
sexual content or hateful content or
really disturbing content in it because
um the content is not manually filtered
by humans
and that training on
this data could eventually lead
big models to behave in a toxic way or
maybe in a biased way
and um
i don't think they criticized only us
for this problem but they said that we
were at the moment um
not careful enough about these topics
and i guess i guess that's one reason
why these big apart from competitive
advantage right a reason why the the
large companies might not release a data
set like this because inevitably
there's even like there there is legit
adult content in imagenet right like
this this data set has been used over
and over there's legit just uh full-on
adult content i've seen it um it's
and i guess these larger companies they
might not release the data set also
because yeah copyright issues
because of of these types of things i
also remember they specifically referred
to the fact that a lot of um a lot of
adult websites they used this alt text
to do search engine optimization
so what they would put in the old text
would be
cl just terms that a lot of people
search for if they cert if they frequent
these websites and that would make it
such that a seemingly
on like
either a seemingly unsuspecting image
would go together with offensive terms
or
seemingly
unoffensive terms would would be like
associated overly with adult themed
images
you know they had some some examples
right there sorry but i interrupted you
so to put everything in a appropriate
light i want to make
some things very very clear
first we do not recommend anyone to
train models with the raw lion data sets
and put this into production without
really careful um
either filtering
or and
thinking about how to make them
safer
so this
is just a research data set that could
also be used by companies for research
purposes or maybe for pre-training and
later making really really thoughtfully
sure
that it's safe
this is the first
the second
from the initial
version i already had some
filters in that tried to generate tags
for non-suit for work and to filter out
obviously illegal content
through clip scores
and this time we improved the non-stick
robot model to become really good
we have now a clip embedding based
classifier where you can
run inference over tens of thousands of
images within a second if you have the
embeddings
and it has on a test set so i made a
november manual test set for non-student
from work
and
the test set has around
3 000 images
and it gets an accuracy of
96 or above 96
so it's already
pretty good and it's really fast
and thirdly
we are also cooperating with um t.u
darmstadt with uh christian castling and
um patrick
schwardowski i hope i pronounce this
name right to use their existing
offensiveness classifier because they
have an offensive content classifier
based also on the embeddings of clip
that also detects things like
violence hate speech
things like bad animals
and um it is really conservative so it
tends to also filter out like
like
halloween costumes and stuff
but uh we are very soon provide
also these
and i think what we are really doing by
releasing all these
samples and not filtering them out in
the first place is we generate a huge
opportunity for safety researchers to
create openly available
non-suited for work classifier data sets
so
everyone who wants to get toxic content
out and
for work content out
is invited here by to work on our raw
data to
generate subsets
and train better tools in the future to
filter those things out
more reliably than we can currently do
and i remember your you're not safe for
work classifier initially was already
pretty good so in this um in this uh
so this this ui you have right here you
i think you have it
maybe not here but i remember you had a
not safe for work but oh safe mode here
obviously i can't show this here since
this is going up to to youtube but i
tried to reproduce some of the results
in that paper and you know for the kind
of egregious results you really had to
actually untick that that box and select
the correct sub model right here uh
because you have you have different
sizes and also different models of clip
that you um
that you had now that is that's probably
gone now but i remember i could select a
different smaller clip model and the
really egregious results i had to untick
the safe mode box i had to select the
smaller clip models which would probably
be less nuanced and uh more more prone
to these kind of things and then i could
reproduce it so um
yeah i'm certainly i'm certainly in
favor of of people you know looking and
saying you know look alt text is often
used for search engine optimization and
that you know can play into that can can
kind of poison the data set
um
yeah but i also feel there's a big
opportunity to use this in a
constructive way although if you if you
like the implication is because you
filter with clip initially
and you still get these images in your
data set
that means clip itself must have been
trained on a lot of data like this right
like it also means that open ai hasn't
managed to to filter out these types of
of images right by implication which is
pretty interesting to think about
yeah that's something related to that
which is interesting is um
so to trend with safety model um
christophe mentioned the training sets
um but for the model we tried several
things and the first thing that
christoph tried was just training and to
under efficient net model
and it worked pretty well and but then
the the issue with that kind of model is
then you need to spend a lot of gpu
resources to do the inference
so when we also tried to use a
small model based on clip embeddings
uh which is then much faster like you
can run overall interference overlay and
finally in one day with just cpus
and what's interesting is that it works
almost as well as the efficient model
which means that indeed clip has that
knowledge like you can test if you add a
few layers of dance if you don't layer
on top it can tell you
whether it's unsafe or not
which actually is a good feature like
you want clip to be able to tell you
that
so yeah that's uh
and yeah
yeah if you uncheck or check safe mode
it will uh enable or not this inference
over the coupon buildings
in live filter out what the model
considers as unsafe
and there is a big opportunity in
actually having clip models that are
trained on
toxic data because it helps later to
detect this and maybe even to generate
synthetic data sets to combat this so
i have been in contact with eunice
androdus from alif alpha the ceo of
alpha alpha and they have their model
magma
magma takes as an input
a clip
the clip output of a frozen clip
and projects this into a gptj
and then can generate captions and do
visual question answering
and
i have seen very interesting results
where
jonah showed me where had been
toxic memes about racial discrimination
and then magma was asked why is this
toxic or why is this eventually
offensive to this meme and magma
generated plausible sounding
explanations for this and i bet this was
cherry picked
but nevertheless
if you would have like potentially toxic
or offensive content you could take any
vqa model maybe that's based on a clip
so you wouldn't have to train it again
and then
generate potential candidate
explanations why is this toxic or why is
this nonsense for work or
things like this
and you could take these candidates show
them humans and let the human just click
okay or not okay and by doing this this
kind of work
um
one could generate easily with far less
human resources huge
safety data sets to explain basically
why something is potentially harmful or
offensive or whatever so i think to have
such kind of models for the research
community um
this is a really good idea and if um
there may be could be some bad actors i
am very sure that they would find
other ways to fine-tune
safe models that we think are safe but
maybe i'm not i so i think
the illusion of believing that my model
is perfectly safe just because i
excluded all the harmful data from it
is a little bit naive because there
could be gaps in the filtering
or harmful actors could take them and
fine-tune them easily so
this is a false safety
instead we should rather train the
research models with a huge disclaimer
and
be aware
that
true safety only can come from
really careful thinking and engineering
i i'm a i think this is a
common way in i don't know like
psychotherapy or something like this
that actually exposure to
danger and exposure to what you're
afraid of and so on is the best way of
of handling these things and you know i
think as these models get bigger i'm
more and more convinced that we should
eventually apply of course if i have a
linear classifier there's not too much
to do but i think these large models
they're capable enough that if if they
actually encounter such data if they
incorporate it and so on they're large
enough i believe that we can teach them
to discriminate internally oh as you say
like you know this is this is probably
not a picture that i should serve at
this particular you know for this
particular search query right here i'm
i'm at i'm at i'm being used at a
wedding to uh portray
you know pictures of the wedding pair
the bride and groom and and the one
where as a child they smear poop in
their face might not be super
appropriate or so um yeah i i think this
is
in my that's just my opinion but i think
this is a good way to go do any of you
of your sponsors
uh have any kind of like
concerns or strings attac you know when
maybe they see criticism coming your way
was this ever an issue with any sponsor
or do you have did you have like
sponsors that were like hesitant because
of these things
no
we don't have so many sponsors we have
doodlebot ai we have huggy face
right thanks to hackeyface and we have
stability ai and um
i think when they read these concerns on
twitter they probably
instantly had opinions that resonate
with our take on this
cool so
where can people get started with this
like i'll link everything in the in the
description what do you think is the
best entry point for people if they just
kind of want to check out what you're
doing
just come on our discord server read
through all the channels that exist
we have channels for
data set creation for audio data set now
there is a audio clip effort going on we
have
dali several dali channels we have
several clip variant channels about
globe and lit and
d philip and d-clip and what all of this
exists
we have some channels where just people
post the generated art the generative
results from
the available
dali variants and glide variants and so
just join
basically i mean you could just reach
out to us
and ask me or someone else if there's a
project where some help could be needed
or you could propose your own project
and if it's cool um
we can try to connect you to some of our
sponsors to get gpus or whatever
cool anything else you want to get out
to viewers listeners
yeah don't hesitate just like even if
you're a high school student or a
university freshman or whatever like
anyone can join like theo comes who was
the first to join the project um when i
started he actually i always believed
that he was something like a master
student or so and later it turned out
that he's a 16 years old high school
student from london and
yeah he didn't know anything about deep
learning at this time now he catched up
but
he was really good at doing all the
server communication and he learned on
the fly so um
we have many many stuff and if you have
your own idea if you would like to to
try to train a style gan or fine tune a
dali version
or whatever just
ask us all right in this case uh kade
homer christoph thank you so much for
being here um thank you for doing this
for anyone yeah check out that the data
set is pretty cool it's a nice
contribution very very cool contribution
to the community
uh thank you and i hope i hope this
continues
thanks thank you so much for having us
[Music]
you